[Musique]
Madana m.  patron wha Devin Devin chats
ce qu'un nouveau caca n'est pas aussi gonflé
émission spéciale dans les extras d'entraînement
ibérico makidai Aleve un premier officier
de agua con Danny Poore Tim de Guerre
les listes étaient faciles à voir le service
de Scientologie ne voulait pas d'Alamo une nouvelle
possibilité  rapidement un volontaire mattah
sarvam Lima Aloha Philippe réserve
décision le tribunal tamoul acosta
France Canada prokinétique j'ai dit quelle
constitution bain élevé avec daya
labas ne doutez pas du kissu Satoshi
Audrey a changé la polémique en
polémique propriétaire dit les cent sur
notre planète un canadien sans maître et politique
lagon Lama le navire Peggy
pop dit développer vous l'excuse des visages est
rafasa récompensé en année de calcul a
causé une bascule commentaires signalés
occasion almohade un pays cajun une
région dollar Toronto moi au bal
abroger la super OTAN à Amelia de
Socotra contre o Mahadeva Taco mardi
à  Casa de manejo Café pakistanais moi une
rébellion paysanne Afghanistan Oh enduit
Oussama  ben Laden
colita Lieberman Lapua Kaboul éléments
efficaces en effet seulement kondal un peu le
terrorisme contre notre nation ne
supportera pas une pilule en septembre do Milla est
américain un janista très dalle
Kelton Watertown Levin a dit que nous ferons
Lauren F automatiquement pour spécial Omar
Khadr Ingrid Mobley voir littéralement fait
tu as encore un sourire sur des trucs
robucket Erica notre transfert de consulat
tu condamnes Guantanamo le passage
diesel est d'accuser le bétail PETA la
violence Allegra et les chats vont attaquer
jon-christopher spear
ce sont des tueurs ce sont des terroristes je
voulais un plus de marché là-bas il totalement
privé un gardien le sien ouvert sur
lui wha
oh [ __ ] pourquoi le lait aux voitures de San Saba
accusation d'Oakland payer la libération de la zakat sur la
console de service un Canadien Omar Khadr
attentif un berger est un John Service
Canada Doha n'a pas chanté la sécurité aime tu fais un
don la formation de gauche était  L'Amérique
vous-même et vous voulez n'importe quel film avec une sélection idiote,
ne répétez pas Lima
déposé amanda persico  grand-mère pauvre
Todd ne manque pas de suprême sur le moulin
VT DeMille lui
déconfirmer au Canada vo Lili le Potomac un
jour à répéter réparer sa photo da Rimini
tomate d'Achille Lamia sur le milieu cet
omekata c'est devenu le jeu celui
commandé militaire Guantanamo -  il est
parti sans calcul IV malade merci chef
de cuisine stylo ouvert le silicium Vita
SATA donc jamais Cardenas Edney dans les
émissions ne permet qu'à ce diable supplémentaire de
s'adapter Je sais
qu'Omar Khadr est un partisan bien connu du
réseau terroriste d'Al-Qaïda
harperman voir clairement  posté hôtel dolor
de cada un septum qui manque Doolittle
pas de transfert il ne raisonne pas pourquoi la
sécurité maximale manque de poupe anohter
vous n'êtes pas güven figure patriotique - Tina -
22 DiMaggio qui cette année nous avons vu
atténuateur ajouter clarifier les services agir
sous le lait n'est pas possible  à travers la France
Canada joli pétoncle indubitablement
DiPaola chromosome inter-américain
toteit réserve V venir en enclos adolescent
faire un don abyssal Pevensie al infirmière au
milieu carotte  détention de raisins secs Omar
Khadr le béret sukoshi o veux dire c'est
ton concurrent gros petit Velma
Je voudrais remercier le
public canadien de me faire confiance et de me donner une
chance
pas de chirurgie coiffure Mindy a dit
nourriture animale locale ou peut trouver des bénéfices même
Devaney do
Kelly's avocado cat  il y a une tante
kala peut s'adapter ou être complète
pour que ma viande soit rare, ce n'est pas que non seulement la
minute dit aux Américains oh macha Davis
Wayne compensation Tony Montana Parkin
remplissez-moi mademoiselle Tamiya a plaidé un
million de dollars la Charte des droits et
libertés protège tous les Canadiens
chacun  d'entre nous, même quand c'est inconfortable,
il ne s'agit pas des détails ou des mérites
de l'affaire fendue lorsque le gouvernement
viole les droits de la Charte des Canadiens, nous
finissons tous par payer pour cela supremo in
shifflett on plan figure pull a um La
Femme or uniform key from fast  dans dong
Jae incroyable pour un serein était la
sécurité du module laser macadam le
puzzle complet aucun chef un tribunal
Saville America Lokhande Neapol  n'est pas sur la
kétamine John de la famille le désordre
- XI de la tequila apaiser la ville de Kadare
pour voir l'équité de la
capacité de leadership d'un ascenseur militaire de la camisa
au nouveau silicium essayé mais je reste
autour de
prigioni merci d'être un désordre
ne jamais voir le  le trafic Naumann jette
encore une fois le pire vendeur d'automobiles merci beaucoup
oh macha leur plus aspirant ne devine jamais
quel son ouais oui vois merci d'
être avec nous merci beaucoup merci
oh macha là c'est un moment très important
dans votre vie ce règlement pour
le  gouvernement après avoir été détenu
treize ans de votre vie
près de la moitié de votre vie qu'est-ce que cela
représente pour vous cela représente une page
tournée dans ma vie et j'espère une nouvelle
page à commencer est-ce que vous vous attendiez à une telle
polémique je pense que je m'y attendais j'avais
j'espérais que les deux dernières années auraient
donné aux gens l'occasion de me connaître
et de rendre mon cas moins controversé, mais
et c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé, que pensez-vous
de cette controverse  Si les gens ont le
droit d'avoir leur opinion, je ne suis ni
bouleversé ni troublé par cela, mais cela
vous apporte une attention indésirable et c'est
quelque chose que je ne veux pas pour le moment. Je
veux juste pouvoir me fondre
et être capable de  dire pour commencer à
continuer ma vie le règlement était
basé sur des décisions judiciaires trois de
la Cour suprême du Canada une
suite à la Cour suprême des
États-Unis différents rapports
confirmant que vous étiez que vos
droits étaient des vues violé une violation de
la primauté du droit  par des responsables canadiens,
vous devez maintenant faire face à un autre procès, celui
du public d'une partie de l'
opinion publique, oui, que pensez-vous du fait
que
ce tribunal de l'opinion publique, je pense, est,
espérons-le, moins affectant et moins
dommageable pour moi parce que dans le passé, ma
liberté  et ma sécurité dépendait
du jugement des tribunaux, mais pour le
moment, c'est l'opinion publique, cela rend les
choses un peu plus difficiles si l'
opinion est trop controversée, mais je pense que
nous allons être  capable de grandir à partir de cette
expérience comment comptez-vous grandir pour
moi Je vais avoir une meilleure appréciation
de ce que les gens pensent de mon cas Je
vais avoir une meilleure appréciation sur la façon
de traiter avec les gens qui n'ont pas de
négatif  vue de moi,
mais je pense que ce sera une
expérience croissante pour la conscience canadienne
pour tout le monde au Canada un autre
défi pour vous aussi parce que nous sommes
confrontés à cette situation les droits de l'homme
sur un faisceau sinusoïdal sont violés vos
droits Le premier ministre Trudeau a déclaré que la
loi le  La Constitution est pour tout le monde
même si c'est inconfortable oui et cette
expérience mon expérience va mettre
tout le monde un peu mal à l'aise mais
ça va nous faire poser les questions et
une fois qu'il y a des questions évidemment
quelqu'un va y répondre donc
c'est un bon débat c'est dommage que
ce soit  ça va être un peu difficile
à gérer pour moi, mais je pense que c'est
une bonne expérience pour le Canada parce que vous
espérez que le règlement
rétablira votre  réputation la rotation est
meurtrier terroriste tueur le fils de
la première famille terroriste canadienne comment
pouvez-vous aller contre cela
comment pouvez-vous aller contre cela contre
les gens qui on l'a dit encore
aujourd'hui on l'a dit depuis le
règlement la chose est le règlement je
ne pense pas que cela ait quelque chose à voir avec
ces titres, ces titres sont nés d'
une frustration, mais ce règlement n'est pas
la cause ou la raison de soulever
ces questions, donc je ne vais pas essayer de
combattre ces titres parce que les gens
auront  cette opinion, je ne vais pas essayer de
changer leur opinion mais vous savez que la
sphère publique va être confrontée à
ces questions et vous savez qu'ils
vont débattre de ces questions et je pense que dans l'
ensemble en tant que pays où nous allons
sortir de cette expérience, le
gouvernement a déclaré que le règlement
est basé sur le fait que des
responsables canadiens ont commis des actes illégaux contre vous en
étant complice des États-Unis
et c'est la base du
règlement  ment oui, de quoi vous souvenez-vous
ou que pensez-vous de cette
phase de votre vie lorsque vous avez été
confronté à des responsables canadiens, nous avons
pu voir dans la vidéo que vous aviez de l'espoir
et nous l'avons vu dans le documentaire et la
vidéo lors de votre première rencontre  Les
responsables canadiens vous espérez qu'ils étaient là pour
vous soutenir mais les choses changent en quelques
jours et après il a été reconnu
que vous aviez été soumis à la torture
avant l'interrogatoire comment allez-vous
vous résiliez bien le premier jour où j'ai
été rencontré I II n'était pas  sûr qu'ils
étaient Canadiens ou non
le deuxième jour, je me suis un peu senti à l'
aise, j'ai commencé à exprimer mes
peurs et mes inquiétudes, puis juste au moment où
j'ai commencé à aborder ces choses,
je savais que j'avais mis mon espoir dans
quelque chose qui avait laissé  moi vers le bas et
c'était très décevant et je pense que
je n'y avais jamais pensé, mais je
pense que depuis lors, j'ai été très prudent
avec vous savez que vous vous ouvrez ou que vous êtes trop
vulnérable et j'ai appris d'eux à
y  ous savez dépendre de moi et me concentrer uniquement
sur moi-même et vous ne savez pas espérer
autre chose que ce que je peux faire par moi-
même
avez-vous senti que vous avez été déçu
par votre gouvernement bien sûr qu'est-ce
que cela vous fait de revoir ces  des vidéos
car le documentaire sera
rediffusé sur notre chaîne te voir
à 17 ans dans une prison en train d'être interrogé
ce n'est jamais facile et jusqu'à présent je ne
me suis pas permis de gérer ces choses
j'ai toujours l'impression que je suis comme si je n'étais pas
tout à fait  hors de l'eau car ils
disent qu'ils ont encore des litiges et des
problèmes juridiques en cours et pour
cette raison, comme je n'ai pas totalement
abordé ces choses, je suis juste en ce
moment, j'essaie de survivre et j'essaie
d'attraper  Je n'essaie pas de gérer
le passé pour l'instant non, cela fait partie d'un
code de survie que vous vous êtes imposé
ouais et je ne peux pas gérer quelque chose
du passé que j'ai l'impression de vivre encore,
donc la peur  de retourner en
prison est toujours très réel,
je suis toujours en liberté sous caution,
donc je c  Je ne commence pas à aborder le passé
et à essayer de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé et à me permettre
de ressentir quand je vis encore presque
sous la peur que ce n'est toujours pas
fait mais que vous ne vous sentez pas complètement libre.
pourtant je suis dans un bien meilleur endroit
que je ne l'étais dans le passé ouais mais il y a
cette ombre qui se profile au-dessus de moi
que tu sais que les choses pourraient cesser de fonctionner,
je pourrais perdre mon appel aux États-Unis et
tu sais que je pourrais retourner en prison
alors c'est très très réel tu as eu une
vie de famille très spéciale est-ce que tu as l'impression d'avoir
été victime de ta famille ou de ton père
précisément à l'époque où ils n'ont jamais
pensé à ces choses c'est trop dur
oh non c'est comme en ce moment je suis seulement
essayer de me concentrer sur les choses que je peux
changer comme si j'étais une victime ou
non  Et
comme tout ce que je fais en ce moment, c'est juste
essayer  g pour me concentrer sur vous savez rattraper
et juste me construire une vie mais
vous voyez-vous comme une victime des
États-Unis ou des responsables canadiens
Je n'aime pas me voir comme une victime Je
sais que non c'était des circonstances malheureuses
et
Je pense que le monde occidental que nous avions, nous avons
tous été mis dans la situation, malheureusement,
j'étais la personne qui a été mise en prison, mais
c'est c'est une question qui a été posée
à toute notre conscience et vous savez, nous l'avons
traitée comme nous l'avons fait et nous  êtes
ici aujourd'hui vous avez été le premier enfant
soldat à être condamné pour crimes de guerre
contre la Convention internationale pour la
protection des enfants pensez-vous
que le règlement fait de vous
un exemple pour le monde ou en
particulier pour les États-Unis que
les droits de l'homme sont  plus peut être combiné
avec la sécurité nationale qu'il n'y a aucune
raison de violer les droits de l'homme au
nom de la sécurité nationale eh bien
tout ce qui se passe légalement crée un
précédent Je suis peut-être une affiche mais un
message  e dans la mesure où ils voulaient
envoyer que le Canada veut être un
pays modèle parce qu'il reconnaît les défauts
du passé les manquements nous avons la chance
ici au Canada d'avoir un gouvernement et
un système judiciaire qui vous savez reconnaît
vous connaissez ses réalisations et  aussi ses
lacunes, nous ne sommes pas en tant que gouvernement en
tant que peuple en tant que système juridique, nous n'avons pas
peur de dire que nous avons fait quelque chose de bien ou que
nous avons fait quelque chose de mal et je pense et
j'espère que cela créerait un précédent ou
vous savez nous ferait  un phare pour d'autres
endroits dans le monde avez-vous déjà
perdu tout au long des années du numéro car
je n'ai jamais perdu espoir mais je n'ai jamais eu beaucoup
d'espoir non plus hein mon espoir était très
limité et très vague donc je n'avais pas
de spécifique  J'espère que vous connaissez une personne
ou un gouvernement ou un moment où je comprends que
tout va être fait J'avais un
espoir très général dans la bonté des gens
J'avais un espoir général que vous sachiez que
finalement tout ira bien
J'ai des espoirs très généraux car  utilisez vous avez
dit juste plus tôt que vous où rien
n'est complètement réglé sauf par exemple
disparaître aux États-Unis pour rétracter
votre plaidoyer de culpabilité parce qu'il a été
enregistré sous la contrainte dites-nous
quel était le choix à l'époque si vous
aviez le choix les choix étaient  Je pourrais
combattre mes accusations devant un tribunal qui a fait sa
loi au fur et à mesure ou et même si
j'avais gagné ou perdu cela
n'aurait rien changé j'aurais si j'avais
gagné ma cause aux États-Unis j'aurais
toujours été  détenu indéfiniment et si
j'avais perdu, j'aurais quand même été
détenu, donc c'était soit me battre, trouver
dans le système que je n'ai aucune chance de
gagner, soit je peux conclure un accord de plaidoyer et
j'espère pouvoir revenir au Canada
et pouvoir me battre  dans un vrai tribunal hmm
et c'était un choix très difficile je ne voulais vraiment
pas prendre l'option que
j'avais prise parce que j'avais le sentiment que
cela arriverait qu'avec mes
aveux les gens vont pouvoir
dire eh bien il a avoué  à ceux-là  des choses donc
il est ces choses il est le criminel
et le tueur que vous savez qu'il a
admis être mais j'ai été mis dans un endroit très très
difficile où je devais soit dire
préserver ma réputation et rester en
prison ou pendant 40 ans je pense
pour le Life Center, personne ne sait pendant combien de
temps ou vous savez prendre ce
choix difficile et j'espère venir au Canada
où j'ai une meilleure chance de le
combattre soit dans le pub dans les
systèmes judiciaires ou en public j'avais une meilleure
chance de faire  ici, mais l'impact
sur vous a fait toutes ces décisions de la Cour
suprême reconnaissant que vous avez été
abusé trois décisions de la Cour
suprême du Canada une de la Cour
suprême des États-Unis disant entre
autres que la
commission militaire devant laquelle ont été jugés
était un tribunal kangourou mais cela a eu un impact
sur vous, mais cela fait partie de votre
histoire non, cela m'a rendu fier de cela de notre
système juridique plus que de toute autre chose,
comme je pourrais toujours dire que vous savez que nous avons en
fait de vrais  tribunaux au Canada, donc
cela m'a rendu fier que notre
système judiciaire soit impartial et capable de
s'isoler de l'influence politique
et cela m'a donné l'espoir que ce n'est pas
complètement noir ce n'est pas complètement je
ne suis pas complètement seul il se
passe des choses  l'extérieur qui, espérons-le,
cause le changement de ma situation
certaines personnes ne reconnaissent pas la
réalité d'un enfant soldat et c'est la
première chose qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas quand
ils parlent de vous et d'autres personnes un
adolescent ne peut pas acheter de cigarettes d'alcool
ou conduire une voiture  quand avez-vous
appris l'existence d'une chose telle qu'un
enfant soldat et comment avez-vous
appris cela,
je pense que je ne le savais pas jusqu'à ce que j'en
parle avec mes avocats, mais j'ai eu
une expérience de croissance intéressante à
Cuba
et je n'en étais pas conscient à l'
époque où je n'en ai pris conscience que très
récemment de la façon dont j'étais à mes
débuts à Guantanamo et de la lenteur avec laquelle j'ai
changé comme dans mes premiers jours j'étais très
facilement influencé je  vous  Je copierais n'importe
qui autour de moi si j'étais avec un groupe de
personnes amusantes Je serais amusant si j'étais avec des
gens qui étaient vous savez
conservateurs Je serais conservateur Je
serais Je serais juste un reflet de
la circonstance du  l'
environnement, puis finalement j'ai
commencé à grandir et à comprendre qui j'étais
et qui je suis et non ce que sont les autres personnes
autour de moi, donc et je ne l'ai pas
reconnu jusqu'à très récemment en regardant en arrière sur
mon passé, donc cela aurait pu arriver avec
votre  propre famille votre propre père l'
influence comment pouvez-vous échapper à une famille ou à
l'autorité d'un père qui
a côtoyé islamiste ma famille est et mon
père c'est c'est une très c'est une
dynamique très intéressante et je n'ai pas pris
le temps d'essayer de  comprendre ce
qui s'est passé exactement les gens me demandent tu sais
ce que mon père à propos de ma famille à ce
moment de ma vie je ne blâme personne
je ne pense pas que ma famille ou mon père
m'aurait volontairement mis dans un endroit
qui me mettrait en danger  a-t-il fait
des décisions qui
nous ont eu un impact négatif peut-être et
définitivement, mais a-t-il volontairement
voulu que nous soyons blessés, je ne pense pas que
ce soit pour ma famille et pas pour mon
père non plus, mais je pense que cela va
prendre du temps pour comprendre aussi quand je manque
votre marché esthétique noona prosavana cilantro
seneca là pour développer ox
[Musique]
laissez-moi bientôt recevoir un chérubin staccato
oh macha oh macha deb juste avant la
pause vous avez mentionné que votre c'est un
sujet délicat un sujet difficile parce que
c'est une famille vous avez dit votre père
ça ne t'aurait pas mis dans une situation où ça
pourrait être où tu pourrais être armé bien
mais les gens qui disent aujourd'hui qu'il
n'aurait pas dû y avoir de règlement c'est
parce qu'ils ont peur que ce
règlement soit un encouragement au
djihadisme vous avez entendu ça  vue de
lane morris turek et soldat même du
parti conservateur qu'en pensez-
vous qu'en dites-vous je ne pense pas qu'il
y aura un encouragement pour le
terrorisme du tout ce qui se passe  e et l'
autre chose est que nous nous tenons à la
primauté du droit, peu importe à qui nous avons
affaire, nous avons une loi qui nous régit
et c'est ainsi que nous devons
nous comporter, peu importe à qui nous avons affaire,
nous avons une loi  nous avons une
constitution et c'est ainsi que vous savez
que c'est ce qui fait de nous une société civile, c'est que
nous avons un ensemble de règles avec lesquelles nous vivons
et que nous respectons et qui nous régissent, donc
peu importe qui sont avec qui nous traitons,
nous devrions traiter  avec eux avec ces
lois, le gouvernement a voulu régler l'
abus de droit contre vous pendant votre
détention pendant la période où vous
êtes soumis à la torture et aujourd'hui
certaines personnes semblent vouloir
vous condamner pour tout cela ensemble non
ils  oui c'est leur droit de penser
ce qu'ils veulent de moi je ne vais pas essayer
de changer leurs avis mais tu sais
au final on est tous des êtres humains on a
nos défauts on a nos atouts
on a nos besoins et ça ne marche pas
Peu importe vos antécédents et votre passé  n'est
pas ce qui détermine qui vous êtes Je pense que
c'est votre présent et j'espère que ce que vous
faites pour votre avenir est ce
qui détermine qui nous sommes vous voyez-vous un jour
comme un défenseur de la paix contre le
djihadisme ou je veux faire quelque chose pour
contribuer à  l'amélioration de Kenna
Canada et à notre vous savez pour l'
amélioration de l'humanité en ce moment, je ne sais pas
exactement ce que c'est, cela pourrait être une
vie publique et pour le moment pour moi,
je pense que la meilleure façon de
contribuer est à travers  la médecine et
aider les gens personnellement et vous savez
si quelqu'un a besoin d'aide ou quelqu'un a
besoin d'aide que je peux fournir peut
-être que c'est ma contribution c'est un
voyage pour chacun de nous pour définir
et comprendre comment ils veulent
contribuer au monde et faire cela
monde un meilleur endroit
les décisions envers vous-même sont basées
sur nos droits nos lois sur l'état de
droit mais la réalité derrière cela est que
ce que vous avez été soumis à la torture
est ce sujet que vous pouvez ta
Je peux en parler dépend de quelle
manière souffres-tu es-tu en colère
es-tu résilient
Je veux blâmer le gouvernement Je ne veux pas me blâmer
pour ce qui s'est passé si je
demande aux gens de me donner une seconde chance
alors c'est juste pour moi tu sais de
donner une seconde chance au gouvernement et
ce n'est pas tout le monde  le gouvernement
ce sont probablement certaines personnes qui ont
pris de mauvaises décisions et donc à un certain
niveau est-ce que je souffre un peu mais je
pense que je suis assez fort et moi et
j'ai beaucoup de soutien et beaucoup de bonnes
personnes autour de moi qui m'aident  moi
pour traverser cette épreuve, donc j'ai un
peu de mal, mais vous savez,
chacun de nous, nous traversons nos
expériences individuelles et nos
douleurs individuelles et vous savez que j'ai beaucoup de
chance d'avoir de bonnes personnes autour de moi pour
m'aider à traverser  c'est ce que tu dis
que tu n'as pas  Cria tes yeux tu
ne sais pas encore pas celui qui enlève
tout pas encore et peut-être que c'est
juste une évasion idéaliste ou peut
-être que c'est juste une façon idéale pour moi d'espérer
que cela résoudrait tout et
réduirait tout mais je ne sais pas ce que tu
ressens  soulagé à un moment donné à cause
du règlement parce que là où vous en êtes dans
votre vie où vous en êtes maintenant dans votre vie
c'est vraiment bien sûr il y a comme un
je suis très reconnaissant comme je me suis
beaucoup amélioré j'ai beaucoup grandi dans le  ces deux dernières
années encore beaucoup de rattrapage mais je
pense que je fais de mon mieux et
j'ai beaucoup de paix en moi et c'est
ce qui me permet de continuer et de me concentrer
sur les choses positives de la vie mm-hmm
toi  je veux étudier ouais oui quelle
est l'importance de l'éducation pour vous c'est très éducation
je ne veux pas être
connu pour mon passé je ne veux pas être
Omar Khadr l'ancien enfant soldat ou l'
ancien DD de Guantanamo en détention je
veux être juste tout  Maher et ce que je suis en ce
moment soit sur où l'étudiant ou O
j'espère que l'infirmière peut être une militante des droits de l'
homme ou tout ce que je veux être Je
veux gagner mon titre personnel Je ne veux
pas simplement être mon passé donc c'est très
important pour moi l'éducation quel est le
chemin maintenant pour cela pour y parvenir
c'est beaucoup tu le vois comme un défi
c'est un peu difficile il y a
beaucoup de rattrapage donc je viens de terminer mon
lycée et je viens de finir quelques
prérequis tu sais j'ai 30 ans
et je le suis encore tu sais je  Je suis très en retard
donc il y a beaucoup de rattrapage à faire
donc c'est un peu frustrant
parfois quand tu sais dans ta
classe tout le monde a 18 et 20 ans et moi
30 penses-tu que tu dois quelque chose aux
gens qui t'ont tous soutenu  ces années,
je n'aime pas utiliser le mot oh non comment,
mais en tant qu'être humain, nous reconnaissons
le bien que les gens nous font et nous sommes
reconnaissants et je suis très reconnaissant pour
[Musique]
tout ce que les gens ont fait pour moi
et le  opportunités qu'ils m'ont données
dans le soutien que j'ai montré et je th  encre,
c'est juste pour moi que vous sachiez transmettre
cela et faire quelque chose de bien pour
quelqu'un d'autre pourquoi avez-vous pensé qu'il était
important de nous parler aujourd'hui
parce que, comme le public français, les
gens du Québec m'ont beaucoup
soutenu même si  nous avons une
barrière de la langue et je suis désolé pour cela
j'ai appris le français et puis ils ont arrêté je
ne pouvais pas le pratiquer mais il y a peut-être
une petite barrière de la langue mais nous avons un
lien humain fort et c'était
important pour moi de faire cette interview
reconnaître ce qu'ils ont fait,
reconnaître leurs efforts et leur
soutien et dire merci beaucoup et
ils seront simplement COO pour tout ce
qu'ils ont fait et tout le soutien
qu'ils m'ont montré, mais que diriez-vous
à un jeune  personne qui pourrait être
attirée par le judaïsme, je dirais que l'
éducation éduquez-vous et
reconnaissez votre identité n'ignorez pas
votre identité reconnaissez-la et
embrassez-la et apprenez-la donc si quelques
identités si votre votre fai  apprenez-le
et éduquez-vous pour devenir comme un
meilleur penseur et un meilleur
penseur critique beaucoup de gens font des actions
basées uniquement sur leurs émotions et les
émotions sont importantes mais nous ne pouvons pas faire de
choix uniquement avec nos émotions, donc comme l'
éducation est très  important et qui
nous prépare à faire face à la controverse
et à pouvoir l'aborder de manière rationnelle et
émotionnelle et à trouver la meilleure façon de
traiter ces problèmes dont vous avez parlé
l'importance de la foi êtes-vous une
personne religieuse Je suis une personne religieuse
mais ma foi est
est  une chose personnelle c'est quelque chose que
je fais pour moi-même et pour mon bien-être
et pour ma tranquillité d'esprit donc c'est
une très grande partie de qui je suis mais c'est une
partie très privée de la raison pour laquelle cela vous-même en
tant que survivant bien je  Je pense que
j'aimerais passer du statut de survivant à
celui de prospère, mais comme ce n'est pas le cas, je ne suis pas
seul, car il y a beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont aidé, donc je peux m'attribuer
davantage le mérite parce que certaines personnes diraient
pourquoi n'est pas en colère  ho  w come is not mad
comment ça se fait tu sais comment ça se fait donc la paix
ou sourions ok practie le pragmatisme
est une grande raison c'est tout il n'y a aucun
avantage j'ai appris à me concentrer sur les choses
que je peux affecter et être en colère ou
être tu sais  en guerre avec moi-même ou les
gens autour de moi ça ne changera pas
le passé et ça ne changera pas le
présent ça pourrait rendre ma propre
vie plus misérable et essayer juste de me
concentrer sur les bonnes choses et les choses
que je peux changer et le  la chose est que la
beauté est bien plus grande que l'obscurité,
comme même en prison, oui, il peut y avoir des
murs, il peut y avoir de la torture, mais si vous
regardez au-delà de ces choses, il y a beaucoup
de beauté à l'extérieur et c'est une question de
choix de choisir de voir si vous
connaissez le dur  les murs en béton ou la
belle peinture blanche c'est une question de
perspective souffrez-vous du SSPT
on m'a dit que j'ai le SSPT je n'aime pas l'
admettre la chose à laquelle je pense que je fais le
plus face est le stress
car en prison votre vie est très
contrôlée  un  nd c'est très petit donc tu
sens que l'urine je sentais que je
contrôlais où en sont les choses à ce que j'ai
fait dans mon environnement limité mais en ce
moment
c'est un grand monde et bien sûr tu ne peux pas
tout contrôler et il y a tellement de
choses à venir  chez toi donc le sentiment
de perte de contrôle me rend
parfois anxieux ou stressé et c'est
la partie la plus difficile mais qu'est-ce que ça fait de
prendre ses propres décisions pour faire ce que tu
veux faire des plans pour l'avenir je ne sais pas
comment  prendre les choses simplement je me
dépasse toujours donc je me fatigue beaucoup je
veux tout faire d'un coup je
ne fais pas de pause car j'ai juste l'impression d'
avoir tellement perdu et j'essaie de
rattraper ça sonne comme  c'est un peu
fatigant mais j'aime quand je suis anonyme
quand je suis quelque part où personne ne me connaît
bien alors quand il n'y a pas d'attentes
personne ne sait qui je suis personne ne s'attend à ce que
je sois d'une manière ou d'une autre Je peux juste être
ce que je veux là-dedans  moment avez-vous
des rêves pour l'avenir pour l'
avenir
je  j'ai des rêves je sais que je l'ai déjà
dit je veux faire quelque chose dans le
domaine médical je veux pouvoir aider les
gens je veux pouvoir voyager et
interagir mais j'ai toujours eu une
fascination pour l'humain  être dans les
gens et je pense que c'est la chose la plus
fascinante dans la vie, c'est les gens
là-bas donc chacun est unique dans chacun
qui a sa beauté unique
en eux
[Musique]
restavek - mon nom est suzet el proceso
para dar el camino a /  - appris est une
conversation wala de boca do mahadeva
une copie no machi de Soto rencontrer un nouvel homme
dit Ibaka a rencontré Reggiano Phillips elle peut
aller voir Greg LeMond avoir de l'énergie économique
mr.  Phillips,
bienvenue à eux, les chats étaient à nouveau sains
merci beaucoup merci oh mon
dieu c'est que vous êtes l'un de vos avocats
comment était-ce de prendre l'affaire aujourd'hui
lorsque Denis m'a approché pour la première fois pour
travailler avec lui c'était une décision de
prendre  sur une affaire, cela allait
changer ma vie et j'étais fier de le faire
pour les problèmes, puis je dois économiser après
avoir rencontré Omar, tout est devenu à propos de lui le
fait qu'il méritait l'effort que
nous mettions dans le dossier et  faire le
travail que nous faisions donc à la fois les
problèmes et l'homme était la différence
avons-nous vraiment vu une personne qui
a trois jugements de la Cour suprême
du Canada en sa faveur étant en
quelques années même la Cour suprême des
États-Unis  y a-t-il des rapports pourquoi y a-t-il
maintenant cette controverse à ce sujet les
règlements que vous avez négociés
pensez-vous bien je pense que si vous écoutez certaines
des déclarations faites par M.
Shearer lors de sa conférence de presse, vous
réalisez l'importance de pourquoi  ce type
d'affaires est présenté non seulement pour
rendre justice et essayer d'
aider Omar à aller de l'avant et à se remettre
de ce qu'il a traversé, mais il est
vraiment nécessaire que les gouvernements de l'
époque tirent les leçons dont ils ont besoin
pour violer  droits de l'homme
et je dois dire que j'ai été consterné d'entendre
M. Shearer répéter efficacement ce que
m.  Harper avait dit quand il était Premier
ministre
malgré les décisions et face
aux décisions de ces trois
affaires de la Cour suprême et face franchement aux
conventions internationales, cela aurait dû
régir la façon dont nous traitions Omar et franchement
comment les États-Unis auraient dû
traiter Omar  et cela a simplement été ignoré et
donc les règlements, quoi qu'ils soient
conçus pour faire où les jugements
éthiques au procès sont censés envoyer un
message au Canada,
ne peuvent pas se reproduire encore et encore. Je crains
que lorsque j'entends M. Shearer dire ce qu'il a
dit cela  s'il arrive un jour au pouvoir,
cela se reproduira et nous aurons un
autre omar sur les bras si vous étiez
surpris que la vie privée Trudeau ait mentionné
que l'organisme de bienfaisance des droits était pour
tout le monde c'est inconfortable qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent dire qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire par inconfortable
ça veut dire ça  s'applique à tout le monde et
ils dépendent quelle que soit l'
allégeance politique que vous avez si vous êtes
libéral ou conservateur ou NPD quelqu'un
avec une position opposée à la vôtre s  jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
protégé par ces droits de la Charte et cela
peut être inconfortable pour vous, mais en tant
que citoyen canadien, c'est votre droit
et nous engageons notre devoir à tous dans
notre pays de protéger cela même dans le
contexte de la sécurité nationale et de la peur du
terrorisme  encore plus dans le contexte de
la sécurité nationale et du terrorisme à la
minute où nous laissons tomber la minute où nous commençons à
perdre notre sens de l'eau les
valeurs civilisationnelles fondamentales sont notre
liberté de la presse l'état de droit la
minute où vous permettez que cela soit érodé alors
votre sécurité nationale  ne
vaut pas grand-chose,
certaines personnes disent que nous avons mené ces guerres pour la
démocratie et pour défendre la primauté du droit.
la politique intérieure doit consister
à chérir et à respecter
ces valeurs occidentales la Charte les
conventions internationales qui font de nous
ce que nous sommes en tant que pays libre êtes-vous
abasourdi par le fait  que E est confronté
à une Monica Dianna n'est pas confronté
au tribunal de l'opinion publique qui le
voit maintenant bien qu'il veuille restaurer sa
réputation d'assassin de terroriste je
pense en toute honnêteté que c'est à peu près la
seule fois mr.  quatre ou Omar ont eu une
chance d'avoir un vrai procès et le
procès devant l'opinion publique vous l'avez
entendu aujourd'hui vous l'avez entendu avant que
le public canadien ne commence avant qu'il ne le
mérite il mérite les droits que nous n'avons
pas réussi à protéger vous méritez  ce qu'il en
retire, où étaient les défauts,
les défauts étaient de ne pas reconnaître
qu'il était un enfant dans un conflit armé
et nous avons une confession internationale
qui parle directement de cette question, donc
les droits qui devraient être accordés, nous avons
ignoré la Convention contre  terreur à la
fois en ce qui concerne mr.  la chater quand il a
été pris à la fois dans les violations de Bagram par
les États-Unis et que cette dame a révoqué les
violations du Canada et des États-
Unis à Guantanamo et c'est
vraiment dommage que cela soit ignoré et je
dois dire que ce gouvernement de l'époque sous le
premier ministre  Trudeau a reconnu
l'impact et l'importance de ces
conventions que la Charte des droits
et c'est ce dont il a parlé avec
la primauté du droit, cela devient maintenant un
problème de coin, un problème politique, pas seulement un
problème juridique, eh bien, je suis stupéfait par cela
parce que le  le problème est que les gens n'ont pas
prêté attention aux faits réels et
ils ne font pas non plus attention à la loi si les
gens veulent dire que mademoiselle citron
qu'Omar aurait dû être traité
différemment malgré le fait qu'il avait
15 ans malgré le fait qu'il ait été torturé
alors si je peux dire cela, nous devrions
retirer notre signature de la
Convention contre la torture avec notre
signature de la Convention relative aux
droits de l'enfant et avec notre
signature de  m le protocole facultatif des
enfants dans le conflit armé alors vous
pouvez avancer jusque-là c'est l'
état de droit comment convaincre les gens
qu'ils sont des droits de l'homme
il y a aussi la sécurité nationale mais pour les
gens c'est la sécurité nationale et le
terrorisme justifie l'exceptionnel dans
la loi même  tailles a été blâmé par le
comité de surveillance pour ne pas
respecter ses droits mais dans les tailles
d'un rapport nous avons appris qu'ils
croient que c'est c'est les lois ici
sont un obstacle ils sont un enfant et et
le district pour leur mission de base
c'est ce qui est écrit dessus  le
mémorandum entre l'ancien directeur
jawed et m.  Cohen des États-
Unis et et c'est le choix que nous
devons faire en tant que civilisation occidentale,
c'est que nos droits
et notre identité de civilisation civile sont ce qui fait de nous ce que nous
sommes si nous voulons abandonner toutes ces
libertés et bien que ces droits et
confondre avec le  l'amour de la
sécurité nationale ne commencera pas à ressembler à la Chine,
ce n'est pas là où je veux être et maintenant pour
l'argent, les
gens disent que personne n'a confirmé que
vous ne le feriez pas normalement pourquoi est-ce
confidentiel que j'ai été fait dans le cadre d'un
règlement par médiation la plupart des colonies
entre les plaideurs sont gardés privés et
celui-ci est censé rester privé cela fait
partie de l'intérêt personnel d'Omar
que ce soit le sien ce qu'il en a retiré
c'est pour lui plus tôt je lui ai posé une
question sur l'argent certaines personnes disent
pourquoi j'espère rempli si  l'argent a vu au
désespoir la famille a dit que c'est l'avocat pour
parler de ce que vous dites aux gens qui
disent qu'ils devraient partager l'argent donner à l'
argent une partie de l'argent nous ne savons pas
le montant je demanderais à quelqu'un  pour
examiner les faits, regardez comment l'affaire a été
tranchée par défaut aux États-Unis,
elle a été entièrement construite sur des déclarations faites
par Omar de Guantanamo à Bagram et
dans ses aveux, tous tirés de la
torture, tous pris alors qu'il avait moins de 15 ans
et tous mis à  lui parle d'un
choix fatal qu'il a dû décider de faire un
plaidoyer de culpabilité pour sortir ou non et quand les
gens deviennent cognitifs, est-ce que cela lit
ce qui est là et comprend les faits
que les jugements ne sont pas justifiables, il est
inadmissible qu'il soit appliqué
au Canada et si  Je peux ajouter juste une
chose à cela, si je me mets à la
place du sergent Spears ou de sa veuve
et que je pense à ce pour quoi je me bats
quand je suis en Afghanistan, c'est en partie la
façon dont les autres cultures que les autres nations
traitent  leurs enfants et ils
traitent mal ses enfants mr.  Cotter
était et il ne dira pas cela je le dirai il a été
une victime en vertu des
conventions internationales il était un enfant dans un
conflit armé il était une personne très gentille
que le sergent Spears était là pour l'aider
ce ne serait pas différent de l'un des
puce  livre des filles qui ont été capturées au
Nigeria qui ont été convaincues par ses ravisseurs
de devenir un kamikaze que c'est en
quelque sorte leur choix et nous allons l'
appeler une terroriste mais Arda écoute pour
être tirée de cette histoire donc nous
ne devrions jamais sacrifier les droits que nous
Des soldats se sont battus et sont morts à travers
des guerres mondiales et des conflits pour faire de notre
pays le meilleur pays au monde
avec un système juridique qui, je pense,
est sans égal au monde, mais vous savez
que les gens ont dit opposé, j'ai dit que je
vais  dire que c'est une gifle aux
anciens combattants
leur vie et qu'il est vivant et qu'il y a
deux problèmes distincts, ce qui s'est passé avec
les anciens combattants, c'est aussi un problème d'
injustice, mais ce n'est pas
lié à ce que nous devons faire quand
s  quelqu'un est mal traité en violation
des droits de la Charte et
des violations environnementales des
conventions internationales indemniser
cette personne et envoyer un message au
Canada est distinct de la façon dont nous
traitons nos anciens combattants devons-nous mieux traiter nos anciens combattants nous le
faisons absolument c'est une question distincte  bien que
comment les gens puissent-ils changer d'avis dans la
façon dont les gens s'attendent à ce qu'il soit
condamné, ce qui représente le paiement de
tout ce qu'il était, mais cette
famille était le champ de bataille sur lequel il
commandait, vous savez que vous étiez, il
déclarait combattant ennemi en moi pour
des États et donc ce qui est
absurde dans notre droit international,
il était un enfant dans un conflit armé qui
aurait dû être la fin de l'affaire
et était une question à laquelle M.
Shearer n'a pas répondu lors de sa conférence de presse,
il était un  enfant dans un conflit armé et devait
se voir accorder les droits que nous disons qu'il
méritait et qu'il n'était pas
maintenant les patrons de tailles n'ont jamais été
jugés responsables b  ut le soutien
des actions de leurs fonctionnaires là-bas l'
un a été promu sous-ministre de la
défense d'autres il est devenu
conseiller à la sécurité nationale pour m.  Harper devraient-
ils avoir été jugés responsables de
l'action, c'est tout le gouvernement
qui doit émettre, je pense que c'est tout le
gouvernement quand vous réalisez certaines des
déclarations qui ont été faites par le premier
ministre Harper et le ministre tabes à
l'époque si c'est la direction qu'ils sont
arriver du haut, ce n'est pas une surprise pour les
gens du côté empirique de Radek ou du côté du
renseignement a agi comme ils l'ont
fait, c'est vraiment dommage de haut en
bas, je comprends que le montant est
confidentiel, mais comment pouvons-nous
déterminer un montant ce qui vaut ce que
le  le montant est conçu pour couvrir deux
choses, l'une est d'aider Omar dans la
réhabilitation et la réintégration dans
la société canadienne lui donner une éducation
et être et le ramener là où il
aurait dû
être traité correctement c'est la partie 1 partie 2
est d'envoyer  un message que les violations des droits de la
Charte et des
conventions internationales seront sanctionnées afin que
le prochain gouvernement qui veut
sacrifier certains de nos droits  pour des
raisons de sécurité nationale ou pour un
autre intérêt politique saura que
cela va coûter cher et que ce coût doit
être suffisamment élevé pour garantir que cela
ne se reproduise plus,
donc ce sont ces deux fonctions pourquoi
pensez-vous mais a convaincu le gouvernement de
arriver à un règlement après ce que 12 ans
de bataille juridique j'aimerais voir
trois décisions de la Cour suprême du Canada sur
le fait qu'ils ont dû s'excuser auprès de
m.  Orr et juste le sens naturel de la
justice oh mon dieu je vous remercie beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir
LT laka Merci mr.  Phillips merci
beaucoup de nous avoir expliqué les
problèmes les batailles juridiques et les problèmes
qui y sont liés c'est très pertinent
quand tu me manques Missy de ce que j'ai laissé
machette
[Musique]